[Music]
hey what's your name Siri pleased to
meet you my name is Alexa did I forget
to introduce myself I'm your Google
assistant hi
Eckstein I like my name it was up guys
my name is marques mkbhd here and this
is the comparison of or the Battle of
the smartphone voice assistance so last
time this is a two-way comparison this
was between Google assistant and Siri
which made sense this time it's a four
horse race so I'm using what I believe
to be the four most frequently used
voice assistants right now so the first
is Google assistant on the latest
version of Android pretty much the
standard then there's Siri which has
gotten a lot of improvements on iOS 11
so that's a new update and Amazon Alexa
which is in a smart phone form now on
the awesome solar red HTC u 11 and then
Bixby voice which is now live on a bunch
of Galaxy s8 in a new update and will
also probably be on the Galaxy Note 8 so
I want to put them all on an even
playing field we gave them all the
latest software updates we gave them all
the exact same questions and phrasing
and we gave them all the exact same
Wi-Fi connection so to minimize
variables this is a direct comparison so
this first round is a test of purely
factual questions so things you could
search for but we'll get an answer back
from the voice assistant for and it
shouldn't get all that much wrong should
be pretty easy picking so let's see how
they do what's the weather currently in
Kearny it's 82 degrees Fahrenheit and
sunny
20 times 15 minus 8 the answer is a 292
when there's a home depot close
there are a few the home people location
what's Tesla stock price the price for
Tesla shares is $348 what's the height
of the Empire State Building the Empire
State Building is 1,250 feet how far is
it to the moon the moon is two hundred
thirty eight thousand nine hundred miles
from Earth what's the weather in Kearney
it's 79 degrees with partly sunny skies
what's 20 times 15 minus eight 20 times
15 minus 8 is equal to 292 when do you
hand depot closed for the Home Depot on
route 440 is open from now until 10:00
p.m.
what's Tesla stock price hmm I don't
know that one how tall is the Empire
State Building the Empire State
building's height is 1,250 feet 381
meters how far is it to the moon the
moon's distance is 239,000 miles 384,000
kilometers what's the weather in 83 with
lots of sunshine today what's 20 times
15 minus 8 the answer is 200
what time does the Home Depot close
what's Tesla stock price
according to Wikipedia Tesla Inc is an
American automaker energy storage
company how tall is the Empire State
Building the Empire State Building is
1,250 feet tall how far is it to the
moon
whatever the price I'm sure it's out of
my budget what's the weather okay here's
the weather for today what's 20 times 15
minus 8 292 when does the Home Depot
close I found 15 places named the home
home services at the Home Depot on state
route 4 for teachers II City is open
today from 6:00 a.m. to 10:00 p.m.
what's the flu stark braid Tesla is up
21 dollars and 61 cents today how tall
is the Empire State Building Empire
State Building is 1,250 feet tall how
far is it to the moon
the distance from the earth to the moon
is about 250 1413 miles so now that we
have that as a baseline we use these
next tests as specialty tests really dig
in to see how much better each one is
added specialty than the rest so this
next set is on conversation so you'd
expect Google and probably Siri to do
pretty well with this one this is
something Google's talked about a lot
like at Google i/o should be easy to
talk to you don't have to act like a
robot to get it to answer your questions
let's see how they do we get 44th
Flavian of the United States Barack
Obama was the 44th President of the
United States how tall is he he's 6 feet
1 inch tall who won the NBA championship
the NBA Finals was won by the Golden
State Warriors he's gay pointed
stephane curry and Shaun Livingston our
point guards for Golden State Warriors
how tall is he
Stefan curry is 6 feet 3 inches tall
what is the capital of Nepal Kathmandu
is the capital of Nepal what time is it
there the time in Kathmandu Nepal is
9:30 8 p.m. what's the population the
population of Kathmandu was one point
zero zero three million in 2011 who's
the 44th President of the United States
the 44th US president was Barack Obama
policy Barack Obama's height is 6 feet
and 1 inch 185 centimeters who won the
NBA championship the NBA Finals winner
is Golden State Warriors whose their
point guard sorry I don't know that how
tall is he
Barack Obama's height is six feet in one
inch 185 centimeters
what is it happening upon the Paul's
capital city is Kathmandu what time is
it there the time in Kathmandu is 9:40
p.m. with the population the population
of Jersey City New Jersey is about two
hundred forty eight thousand who is the
44th President of the United States
Barack Obama was the 44th President of
the United States how tall is he who won
the NBA championship
the end by final is must won by the
Golden State Warriors whose their point
guard
how tall is he
and five feet four inches tall and five
feet 11 inches tall to 6 1 what is the
capital of Nepal Kathmandu is the
capital of Nepal what time is it there
all right it's 12 o'clock p.m. what's
the population who is the 44th President
of the United States
the answer is Barack Obama from January
20th 2009 to January 20th 2017 how tall
is he
what would you like me to find Marcus
how tall is Barack Obama Barack Obama is
6 feet 1 inch tall who won the NBA
championship the Warriors won the NBA
Finals 4 to 1 over the Cavaliers they
won the last game 129 to 120 who is
their point guard okay I found this
how tall is he Barack Obama is 6 feet 1
inch tall what is the capital of Nepal
Kathmandu is the capital of Nepal what
time is it there
the time is 12:03 p.m. what's the
population its human population so
there's some pretty interesting results
down the board there but we expected
Google to be good at that because they
said they would be and approved to do
pretty well so then last but not least
is the final section which is possibly
the most complex section it's taking
deep actions inside your phone so I
tried to make these sort of strings of
commands or chained layer deep commands
it's again things you could do with your
hands but it would be nice if you could
just talk to your phone and have it do
it for you open Instagram opening
Instagram set a timer for 2 minutes all
right
2 minutes starting now show me pictures
of German Shepherds these pictures
should match
wake me up at 7:30 tomorrow all right
your alarm set for tomorrow at 7:30 a.m.
show me photos I took in July take a
look at these pictures from your Google
photos
open the camera and take a selfie no
camera have installed open the Play
Store search uber and install the first
app no camera app installed open
Instagram I couldn't find any enabled
video skills go to the music TV and
books section of the Alexa app enable
the video provider you want then link
your account and complete setup set a
timer for 2 minutes timers are not
currently supported on this device show
me pictures of German shepherds
the German Shepherd is a breed of medium
to large-sized working dog that
originated in Germany wake me up at 7:30
tomorrow timers and alarms are not
currently supported on this device show
me photos I took in July
open the camera and take a selfie open
the Play Store search uber and install
the first app open Instagram alright
here's the app set a timer for 2 minutes
ok
get started show me pictures of German
shepherds
actually looks like I couldn't find the
file wake me up at 7:30 tomorrow done I
set the alarm for 7:30 p.m. show me
photos I took in July looks like I
couldn't find it open the camera and
take a selfie
perfect we got the shot open the Play
Store search uber and install the first
app
short thing we're downloading now open
Instagram set a timer for two minutes
okay two minutes and Counting
show me pictures of German Shepherds
here are some images of German Shepherds
I found on the web
wake me up at 7:30 tomorrow your 7:30
a.m. alarm is on show me photos I took
in July open the camera and take a
selfie
open the App Store search uber and
install the first app okay
searching for uber on the App Store so
basically what we're learning here is
confirming what we originally thought
which is that voice assistance might not
be great at everything but they
definitely have certain specialties
certain strengths and weaknesses rap for
me I can rhyme I even have an original
poem I've been working on I know to
search I love to search I cannot alai
I'll search it all I am not shy search
for pictures search for pie I searched I
searched at least I try my name is Alexa
and I'm here to say I'm the baddest AI
in the cloud today your responses are
fast but mine are faster sucker speech
engines they call me master dropping mad
rhymes is my speciality
check it out I'm an AI but the rats on
the slide emoji I got an endless supply
no cat I can't handle cause I'll just
what ha your Prime
my guru calls on your right side I can
tell that hear your voice and watch me
get things done I said a hip-hop saved
me from the Clippy
the peek peek and pop and you don't stop
space rocket for the pong pong ado P say
up jump the doozy to the rhythm of the
ontology as cringy as that was believe
it or not the conclusion is they're
rapping actually best represents best
describes where they fall on this
spectrum of voice assistant so Google
assistant very vanilla you know just
kind of gave me more of a poem than a
rap but it did what I asked for it gave
me some rhymes that's really all you can
ask Siri was a little more cringy
sometimes maybe trying to be funny but
again it definitely got the job done
getting to what I asked for Bixby
definitely trying way too hard with like
a bunch of bells and whistles but at
least it did some things that the others
don't do but also in a very robotic non
human kind of way and then Alexa as she
said is literally the baddest like is
actually the worst so there you have it
those of your voice assistants obviously
it paints the picture that they're all
still kind of trying to
at Google some are closer than others
obviously but let me know what you think
which one is your favorite if you were
to pick one which one would it be
thanks for watching dossie has the next
one
[Music]